all right so i meant to get this video
to you yesterday
and then i was like i could do a video
today
or i could play through the game again
on new game plus get that last trophy so
i can get my platinums but i
did that instead which i guess is a
testament to this game and how fun it is
because i wanted to play through it
again so there is that
anyhow we have work to do
[Music]
spider-man miles morales and full
disclosure since honesty is important
they did send me this copy for free
but my thoughts are still my own i mean
turns out i like spider-man
so it's probably a smart move on their
part but still spider-man miles morales
is a new spider-man game in the vein of
the spider-man game that came out for
ps4
it's the same world as that game in that
game you saw the intro of miles morales
and now
miles has his own game in which you play
as him one of the things i will say
right out the gate if you were a fan
of the spider-man game before you're
gonna jump right into this kind of like
riding a bike in terms of the punch
punch punch
launch an enemy swing kick an enemy
those basic moves are the same so you
can get right into it from there
swinging around the city you have your
scavenger hunt elements in here but
the game goes to great lengths to let
you know that you are not playing as
peter parker
this is a different person and they do
it wonderfully right from the music
the music in this okay the soundtrack
should have a vinyl release and when
they do
is going to be mine i mean i have it
right now on compressed muddy ass mp3
but
this soundtrack is worthy of the vinyl
release that's inevitably going to
happen because the music
sounds familiar when you're swinging
around new york you're like this is the
spider-man music
but it has that hip-hop beat to it it's
so epically mixed to give it that
spider-man flavor
but also miles morales also the way he
moves is different when you're swinging
around the city there's something clumsy
yet stylish about it he's not just
swinging he's falling with style
and i like the fact that he moves
differently than peter parker it would
have been so easy for them to be like
well i mean we we do have the swinging
animations from the previous game we can
just put miles morales clothes on there
the miles morales spider-man suit and
look at that voila
new spider-man and it would have been so
easy to do this would have been lazy as
[ __ ] but they didn't do that they went
out of their way to make you feel like
oh this
is not peter parker this is miles
morales complete with new moveset
because miles morales spider-man has
different moves than peter parker
spider-man you turn invisible you have
venom strike really powerful things you
can upgrade in here though
on a couple of those stealth missions i
was like i could really go for some
impact webbing
i'm just saying but that's to the point
if you mastered the previous spider-man
game the new
moves in here it's like but you haven't
mastered these so you have things to
learn here new moves as well as new
outfits which when i unlocked the spider
verse outfit i used that for a
solid portion of the game and i love the
fact they have this
mod that you give the suit that makes
him move in the frame rate from the
movie
i just that's a good bit of fan service
and i just love that i also love that
outfit where he has the jacket and the
hood
that's just a cool looking outfit but
most importantly the character of miles
morales you're playing as the family
dynamic the supporting characters how
are they they're the ones who are going
to
bring me into the game and make me
really care about miles morales and yeah
it pulls it all off when spider-man
takes off miles
is now new york's only spider-man for
the next few weeks and he has to step up
in some
really big ways to save the day i mean i
love spider-verse and all like his intro
in the ps4 spider-man and spider-verse i
was like oh yeah i like the kid he's
cool but now i'm like
i like spider-man he's spider-man i mean
peter parker's also spider-man and
that's why
miles is kind of a gold standard of how
you introduce a new character
to be a new hero with the same name as
the old hero
they don't replace each other they don't
cancel each other out or anything but
you
welcome him with open arms because miles
is
[ __ ] awesome he's a good kid he has a
good heart he just wants to do
right he exhibits the qualities i like
about
spider-man i got attached to him i got
attached to his family i mean the
the whole scene with his dad in
spider-man
ps4 game yeah i mean that stuff gets you
right there you're like oh that's a hook
that's
oh man i mean the family dynamic is an
important element in a spider-man story
to me anyway that's just
that's a thing that hooked me when i was
younger also i like the villain i mean
there are a couple people who are doing
less than altruistic things in new york
at this time
but point is the main one it wants to
focus on is
you get where the villain's coming from
you understand you empathize you
sympathize
miles morales does too however this is
not the way
it's one of those villain dynamics where
you're like i get why you're doing
but you gotta understand what you're
doing in terms of the technical elements
not gonna get too technical i'm not a
tech channel but it being on ps5 we
gotta talk about some of the flair that
ps5 has to offer with this game first of
all the load times yes they're insanely
short and we know that because the
previous spider-man game you know you're
like oh
fast travel you know and you'd be on the
subway and he's on the subway just
hanging out
doesn't even give you that animation
it's like you want to fast travel sweet
now you're there like in the previous
spider-man game i was like well fast
travel is pretty relative
generally speaking unless it's across
the city you could probably swing there
faster like if it's just
the next sector over that's what i found
anyways how it seemed anyhow in this
game fast travel is truly just
faster also graphically you have 4k at
60 frames a second or 30 frames a second
with
ray tracing which is a way of saying
details are better but
30 frames a second instead of 60. first
playthrough i played through with all
the jazzy ray tracing second playthrough
was at 60 frames a second neither of
which i can show you here because i
don't export my videos in 4k
or 60 frames a second but they both look
great in their own way so which one you
want to do that's completely up to you
but one thing i know for certain
is pc gamers are out there like they
have to pick between the two
that's precious whatever the thing that
might throw some people off is
the game is comparatively short for sure
it is reflected slightly in the price
and the fact that the game's 49.99
instead of 59.99 we're gonna round is 50
bucks instead of 60 bucks now if you're
gonna compare it i don't know if the
previous spider-man game is 20 percent
longer than the miles morales spider-man
game to
100 percent reflected in the price i
don't think so i think
the gap between the two is a little
longer and that's where you have to keep
in mind
they sent me the game for free this is
part of the reason i don't like getting
[ __ ] for free in terms of review
but i like getting things for free
because it kind of feels cool but just
keep in mind when i say like
the game is still fun you know like
would i drop 50 bucks on this game
yeah i mean it's 50 dollars worth of fun
if you're going around picking up all
the stuff and
that's what i'm saying here is all the
side quests go into the price
whereas when i'm usually buying a game i
like the core story to feel like a full
game then okay we can
have a bunch of side quests that really
beef it up and really pat it now to get
your money's worth out of this game in
terms of length you have to do all the
side quests because when i did new game
plus you keep all your gear so
you're just powered up ready to go you
can go right through the core game you
don't even have to do the side quests
in that man it's not that long the core
game is pretty short but this game
played it in the pocket and
gave me what i like which is a great
story about a hero who doesn't start out
feeling like a hero and through that you
get attached to him it's an inspiring
story it really is
i wanted to go around and clean up all
the crime not just because i wanted to
feel like i played a complete game but
because i wanted to be the hero that
miles is i loved into the spider verse
but there's something about
a well-constructed game that will get me
more attached to the main character
it's the way it is and this game is that
i thought spider-man miles morales was a
worthy successor spin-off whatever you
want to call it it was a worthy
spider-man game
with a worthy spider-man hero that i'm
happy to call
spider-man alright so spider-man miles
morales have you played it what did you
think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
you